Dr. Scholl's.
Born to Move.
>> FINALLY TONIGHT, THIS WEEK'S
EDITION OF "NOTABLE QUOTABLES" "
>> President Trump: I AM
WAITING.
>> WHEN HE GOT THIS LETTER FROM
THE PRESIDENT, HE MUST BE HAVING
A GIGGLE FIT.
>> I THINK THE PRESIDENT DIDN'T
WANT TO BE PLAYED WITH.
HARDER THAN THE ART OF THE DEAL.
>> WE WILL CRUSH THEM.
>> GAS PRICES COULD KEEP GOING
HIGHER ALL SUMMER LONG.
♪ ♪
I HATE THAT ROBERT MUELLER ♪ ♪
>> THE SWAMP HAD NEVER BEEN MORE
FOUL OR FETID THAN UNDER THIS
PRESIDENT.
>> President Trump: HE IS A
WORLD-CLASS POKER PLAYER.
>> THIS IS NOT QUID PRO QUO OR
ANYTHING ELSE.
>> WE WANT PEOPLE TO RESPECT THE
NATIONAL ANTHEM AND TEST STAND.
>> I STAND ON THE SHOULDERS OF
HEROIN, WHO NEVER FOUGHT PUBLIC
ACCLAIM.
>> I CAN ATTEST THAT ONE CAN BE
CHIEF JUSTICE WITHOUT BEING A
BIG WHEEL OF ANY KIND.
>> EVEN TATTOOS.
SAY, MR. PRESIDENT, YOU HAVE TO
CHANGE YOUR PHONE, IT'S A
SECURITY RISK.
WHEN YOU AT LEAST DO THAT FOR
AMERICA?
>> I HAD TO JUMP A WALL TO BE
HERE.
>> IF YOU CAN'T BEAT THEM, JOIN
THEM.
>> THAT IS ALWAYS AN AWESOME
MOMENT WHEN THE MIDST TOSSED HER